en este autobús descansan las últimas
esperanzas de miles de haitianos después
de pasar la noche debajo del puente del
río donde se encuentran cerca de 14.000
migrantes en una situación crítica los
recién llegados esperan su boleto el
objetivo final trasladarse a alguna
parte de los eeuu en donde los esperan
sus familiares
la labor de varios voluntarios locales
está lejos de ser suficiente para
hacerle frente a la crisis el
departamento de seguridad nacional de
eeuu anunció seis puntos claves para
enfrentar la situación migratoria entre
los que se encuentran el traslado de los
migrantes irregulares para que sean
procesados y la coordinación de vuelos
de retiros y haití dentro de las
próximas 72 horas además el texto
estipula la mayoría de los migrantes
continúan siendo expulsados bajo la
autoridad del título 42 de los cdc dicha
norma hace referencia al mecanismo de
expulsión acelerada que permite que una
persona sea deportada del país sin una
audiencia ante un juez de inmigración a
raíz de la cual según la oficina de
aduanas y protección de fronteras entre
octubre de 2020 y agosto de 2021 se
expulsaron cerca de un millón de
personas en la frontera suroeste
la cifra se le suma a los 1.3 millones
de migrantes arrestados en la frontera
con méxico desde que biden llegó al
poder y ponen en entredicho las promesas
del mandatario de revertir la política
migratoria de su antecesor donald trump